the further reduction in Russian gas
Imports the rush to fill up gas storage
before the winter and the damaging of
the nordstream 1 pipeline drove
wholesale gas prices in Europe to new
highs over the summer
as shown in the in the blue line on the
right our economy forecast is
conditioned on Market expectations for
gas prices over the next three years
which we then hold constant in real
terms in the final two years of the
forecast
based on the average of the Futures
curves over the three days to the 26th
of October gas prices are expected to
reach a peak of around three pounds 70
per phone in early in early 2023 and are
roughly double the level of our March
forecast over the year
prices then fall back to around one
pound ninety percent in the mid-2020s
which is still four times higher than we
were used to before the pandemic
the government's energy price guarantee
limits average household energy bills to
2 500 pounds this winter and three
thousand pounds next winter
insulating households from the even
larger increases in energy bills that
they would have faced a similar scheme
that that limits the increase for energy
costs for businesses is is in place
until March
however these schemes do not change the
price of energy in the medium term so
sustained High Energy prices act as a
drag on productivity and potential
output as we explored in our fiscal risk
Support over the summer
as inflationary as inflationary
pressures are built up Market
expectations for the rise in the Bank of
England's policy rate shown on the left
have also risen from a peak of around
two percent in our March forecast shown
in green to around five percent in the
print of the curve used in our latest
forecast shown in blue
as you can see from the chart on the
right longer term interest rates on UK
government debt have also risen
dramatically and are now two to three
times higher than we expected in March
the guilt rate curves used in our fiscal
forecast shown in blue were taken in the
first 10 working days of Rishi sunax
Prime ministership starting on the 24th
of October and see yields Peak at just
under four percent at the 20-year mark
as you can see from the yellow lines
interest rate expectations have come
down somewhat since the market
convulsions that followed quasi-quartex
growth plan on the 23rd of September
which saw 20-year yields rise to four
and a half percent the following working
day
and while some of that late September
spike in yields reflected an increase in
the interest rate differential between
the UK and other sovereigns that
increasing spreads had orbit disappeared
by the time we finally closed our fiscal
forecast
in addition to these largely external
influences fiscal policy here at home
has also been a key source of
uncertainty since March
the past six months have witnessed a
series of dramatic swings in the
direction of fiscal policy with five
major fiscal statements delivered by
three successive governments
this chart illustrates the cumulative
effect of those statements on government
borrowing over the next five years
starting with then chance Liberty sunax
26th of May cost of living package which
added 9 billion pounds to borrowing in
this financial year with Savings in
subsequent years from the new energy
price Levy energy profits Levy
fast forward to the 8th of September and
then prime minister Liz truss's original
energy price guarantee and equivalent
support for businesses added 70 billion
pounds to borrowing over the next two
years
to this large near-term loosening
the personal incorporation corporation
tax cuts in the in then Chancellor quasi
quatings 23rd of September growth plan
would have added a further 48 billion
pounds to borrowing over the median term
but almost all these tax cuts were
reversed in Chancellor Jeremy Hunt
statement of the 17th of October with
the main Survivor being the ditching of
the Health and Social care Levy which
brought the net medium term loosening
down to 21 billion pounds by 2027-28
and finally today's Autumn statement
delivers a further package of net tax
Rises and spending cuts which reduce
borrowing by 62 billion pounds by 27 by
2027-28
and taken together and including their
indirect effects via the economy the net
impact of this series of announcements
and reversals has been to add over 40
billion pounds to borrowing this year
and then take almost 40 billion pounds
off borrowing by 2027-28
those three big movements in energy
markets interest rates and government
policies since March all have big
implications for the economic and fiscal
Outlook over the next five years and let
me start with our implications for
inflation
we now expect inflation to Peak at 11.1
percent in the fourth quarter of this
year driven by higher Global energy and
food prices in particular
that's two and a half percentage points
higher at its peak than we forecast back
in March but the peak is two and a half
percentage points lower and one quarter
earlier than it would have been without
the energy price guarantee as
illustrated by the dotted line on the
charge
inflation is unexpected to fall back
sharply over the course of the next year
and is dragged into negative territory
in the middle of the decade before
returning to its two percent Target by
the end of the forecast period
but in the near term inflation the far
outpaces growth and nominal wages which
are expected to grow by six percent this
year and four percent next year
this drives historically large Falls in
per person real disposable income which
drop by a cumulative seven percent over
the two Financial years to 2023-24
wiping out the last eight years of
improvement
this steepfall in living standards
happens despite the energy price
guarantee and other government support
which raise real incomes by three and a
half percent on average this year and
next
however for a net energy importer like
the UK the huge increase in global gas
prices over the past year represents the
terms of trade shock that leaves our
country as a whole forum
so our government policy can through
spending Taxation and borrowing alter
who in the UK pays for these high energy
costs within and between Generations it
cannot make them go away
indeed we expect real incomes in 2027 to
still be one percent below their
pre-pandemic peak of three years ago
this squeeze on real household incomes
drags down consumption and tips the
economy into a recession lasting just
over a year from last quarter
Peak to trough real GDP Falls by just
over two percent but it would have
fallen to half as much again in the
absence of government support
this Fallen output is much shallower
than those experienced during the
pandemic or the 2008 financial crisis
but similar in depth to that scene
during the recession of the 1990s
high energy cost interest rates and
corporate taxes also reduce business
investment over the next few years with
longer term implications which I'll come
back to in a few slides
this week our output combined with the
downward Visions to out turn data over
the last two years mean that real GDP
doesn't return to its pre-pandemic level
until the end of 2024 and remains over
three percent lower at the forecast
Horizon than we expected in March
turning to the implications of the labor
markets the recession leads to another
modest bike in unemployment seen on the
left which Peaks at just under five
percent in the third quarter of 2024.
before falling back to its assumed
structural rate of just above four
percent by the late 2020s
more worrying for the long-term health
of the UK economy has been a continued
rise in the number of adults classes
inactive or outside the labor force
since the start of the pandemic
as shown on the right this means that
the overall size of the labor force is
shrunk by around 300 000 people since
the pandemic
and while we assume that some of these
currently inactive will eventually
rejoin the labor force the prevalence of
older people in this group suggests that
many never will
and the net result is that the overall
employment rate of the adult population
is around a full percentage Point lower
by the end of the forecast period than
on the eve of the pandemic
this brings me to our latest estimate of
potential output or the supply side of
the economy which has attracted
particular attention in the run-up to
this forecast
our forecast for growth and potential
output shown in the middle of this slide
is lower in the near term but unchanged
at the end of the forecast compared to
March
however as you can see from the chart on
the right the composition of that growth
has slightly changed to reflect a number
of largely offsetting developments in
the drive as a potential growth since
March
first we revised up our estimate of the
labor supply of labor Supply growth to
reflect continued high levels of
immigration since the introduction of
the new post-brexit migration regime
second we revise down our estimate of
the contribution of capital deepening to
reflect the impact of the recession and
a higher cost of capital on the volume
of business investment
third we've revised down our estimate of
growth in measured productivity to
reflect the consequences of higher
energy prices
all in all that leaves our assessment of
the rate of growth and potential output
at the forecast Horizon unchanged at one
and three quarter percent a year
this medium-term growth rate is as you
can see from the chart on the left a
full percentage Point lower than the
average growth in the decade prior to
the financial crisis and one-third of
the on one-third of the percentage point
below the post-financial crisis average
but despite that our forecast for actual
growth in the medium term remains
slightly above that above the
independent forecasters and for all
those wishing to know even more about
how we produce our potential output
forecast we've published a briefing
paper on this topic alongside today's
e-foam
let me now turn to the latest fiscal
Outlook taking account of the more
challenging economic backdrop of the
over the next five years and the net
result of the array of fiscal policy
announcements over the past six months
having fallen from its post-war peak of
15 of GDP at the height of the pandemic
to below six percent of GDP last year
boring is set to rise again this year to
just over seven percent of GDP before
falling back to just over two percent of
GDP by 2027-28
in cash terms borrowings nearly 80
higher this year and almost 4 8 80
billion pounds higher this year and
almost 40 billion pounds higher in five
years time than we forecast in March
to understand what drives this
deterioration in the fiscal position
this chart breaks down that increase in
cash borrowing into first differences
arising from underlying forecasting
changes children shades of blue
second changes arising from the net
effect of policy decisions shown in red
for spending and yellow for tax changes
and third the indirect or second round
effects of these policy changes by their
impact on the economy and the debt
interest paid on New borrowing shown in
purple
starting with the blue underlying
forecasting changes add on average 55
billion pounds to borrowing in each of
the next five years
three large changes dominate this higher
interest rates adding to debt servicing
costs higher inflation and inactivity
adding to welfare spending and a weaker
economy Weighing on receipts
looking at the effect of policy changes
the May and September cost of living in
energy packages at around 60 billion
pounds of spending this year and around
25 billion pounds to spending next year
Cuts in departmental spending plans over
the remaining three years save around 30
billion pounds in the final year the
forecast with three fifths coming from
current budgets and two fifths coming
from Capital budgets
tax changes cost money next year but
raise money in the final four years as
the revenues lost from scrapping the
Health and Social care Levy are more
than offset by increases in other taxes
with a net yield of eight and a half
billion pounds in the final year of the
forecast
indirect effects reduce boring
materially in the near term by
supporting incomes and lowering
inflation but raised boring modestly
after that due to debt interest costs
and fiscal consolidation Weighing on
economic activity
taken together these changes leave the
level of borrowing around 85 billion
pounds higher in the next two years and
around 40 billion pounds higher in five
years time
where does all this leave levels of
Taxation and expenditure in five years
time
the tax burden sets a rise from 33 of
GDP before the pandemic in 2019-20 to
over 37 of GDP in 2027-28
which is around one percentage Point
higher than we forecast in March and its
higher sustained levels since after the
second World War
this High tax burden pays for a larger
state whose expenditure rises from 39 of
GDP before the pandemic to 47 of GDP
this year before falling back to 43 in
five years time
this leaves public spending around three
percent of GDP larger than we forecast
in March and its highest sustained share
of econ of the economy since the 1970s
this increase in the overall size of the
state of the medium term is driven by a
combination of higher inflation and
interest rates which push up the cost of
the government's inflation index welfare
commitments and the service and and
servicing its higher stock of debt
and these increase and these increases
more than offset the cuts to
departmental budgets in the final three
years of the forecast leaving overall
government spending higher in cash terms
and more importantly as the share of an
economy made smaller by the energy price
shock
this slide looks in more detail the
implications of those reductions in
departmental spending beyond the current
spending of you period ending in 24 25.
at the time of our March forecast the
total envelope for departmental or
departmental resource or current
spending or current expenditure was
expected to grow at around two and a
half percent in real terms from the
middle of the decade
this resource envelope was sufficient to
allow the government to meet an array of
medium-term spending commitments and
pressures including growing Health
spending by 3.1 percent a year in real
terms continuing the underlying growth
rates in health in the current Sr period
growing defense and overseas aid
spending alignment GDP and holding core
School spending per pupil constant in
real terms
and this would have left sufficient
resources for the budgets of all other
government departments to rise by 2.8 a
year in real terms in the next Sr period
but the removal of 18 billion pounds
from the resource envelope by 2027-28 In
This Autumn statement means that total
spending now total spending now only
Grows by one percent a year in real
terms over the next spending a view
period
and meeting the aforementioned pressures
and commitments and health defense Aid
in schools within the smaller envelope
would now apply real terms cut of 0.7
per year in the remaining spending
while significant cuts on this scale are
smaller than those planned in sr10 and
sr15 which planned real cuts of five and
three percent for such unprotected
departments
however one needs to bear in mind that
it's the same group of departments that
have borne the brunt of successive real
Cuts over more than a decade
and at the base from which the next
squeeze will apply in 2024-25 has
already been squeezed by the decision to
not reopen the cash limits set in the
October 2021 spending review to
compensate many of these departments for
much higher inflation in the meantime
so what we consider the revised path for
public spending beyond the current SRU
is to be plausible it's not without
risks as we spell out in the efo
turning to what this implies for the
stock of debt compared to our March
forecast headline debt is higher as a
share of the economy in every year and
by 17 of GDP in the final year
including the net including the net debt
of the bank of England it rises from 97
of GDP last year to a peak of 107 of GDP
in 2023-24 its highest level in six
decades and then Falls of the remaining
four years of the forecast
but this path is somewhat distorted by
the repayment of around 150 billion
pounds of loans issued by the bank's
term funding scheme
excluding the bank underlying debt rises
from 84 of GDP last year to a peak of 98
of GDP in 2025-26 and then Falls
modestly over the final two years of the
forecast
this higher stock of debt coupled with
much higher interest payments means that
the share of public Revenue being
consumed by interest payments has risen
dramatically since the spring
we expect that interest costs to rise
from under five percent of revenues in
2019-20 to eight and a half percent of
revenues in 2027-28 having spiked to a
post to a high of 12 this year
it's not just the scale but also the
speed at which higher interest rates and
inflation have pushed up debt servicing
costs that's a warning to this in future
chancellors
as we've underscored in successive
reports on fiscal risks three
developments in recent years have
greatly increased the sensitivity of the
public finances to changes in borrowing
costs since the start of the century
the first is the increase in the debt
stock itself which is almost quadrupled
from the 28 of GDP that it was in 2000
2001 to 102 of GDP by by 2022-23
the second is the associated rise in
inflation link debt which has risen from
6 to 22 percent of GDP and for which any
inflation surprises directly increase
the stock of debt rather than erodus
real value
and the third is the shortening of the
effective maturity of that debt as a
result of the quantity of using
operations of the bank of England
this has reduced the medium-term
maturity of debt on the cons of the
Consolidated public sector from seven
years in 2008 before QE to less than two
years now
the combined effect of all these changes
has been to leave the public finances
much more exposed to interest rates and
inflation movements than before
and to illustrate this in today's money
every one percentage Point rise in
short-term interest rates now adds 13
billion pounds of debt interest costs
the following year rather than just two
billion pounds if we had the same debt
level and structure as in the year 2000.
the heightened sensitivity of the public
finances to higher inflation and
interest rates more than explains why
government has missed both of its
currently legislated fiscal targets
set by then Chancellor sunac last
October they included targets to get
underlying debt falling as a share of
GDP and balance the cap of the current
budget three years into the forecast
2025-26 in this forecast
these legislative targets are set to be
missed by 11.4 billion and 8.7 billion
in this forecast
but as he deals with the fiscal
consequences of this energy shock the
current chancellors propose a new set of
fiscal Targets in his Autumn statement
the first rule is to ensure that
underlying debt is falling after five
years rather than three
in the absence of new policy measures he
was on course to miss this target by
28.9 billion pounds with them he's met
it with 9.2 billion pounds to spare
the second rule is to bring overall
borrowing below three percent of GDP by
the end of the forecast
boring was set to be 3.7 of GDP post
measures it's 2.4 percent meaning this
target is met with 18.6 billion pounds
despair
but the margins by which these new
targets are met are historically small
and the risks around our forecast right
now are large
the Outlook would be considerably
brighter or a rapid end to the right to
Russia's war in Ukraine to stabilize
European energy markets reducing
pressures on inflation and interest
rates that could also spur Investments
and productivity growth over the medium
term and get debt falling faster
but should the Ukraine war last longer
and higher energy prices and inflation
persist there are several downside risks
to worry about
energy related support to households and
businesses much like the furlough scheme
during the pandemic could prove
difficult to withdraw as their deadlines
draw closer
other supposedly one-off measures such
as the temporary business rates relief
for the retail and Ledger sectors and
the household support fund are now
heading into their fourth years at a
cost of over 3 billion pounds next year
inflation is putting pressure on
departmental spending eight and a half
billion pounds has been found this
Autumn statement to top up Health social
care and schools budgets in 2024-25 but
other other departments face a reduction
in real-time spending power are between
5.3 billion pounds and 15.3 billion
pounds depending on your choice of
inflation index
and next April's planned super
indexation and fuel duty is assumed to
bring in 5.7 billion pounds in Revenue
next year in our forecast but would now
require a rate increase of 23 percent
summary Rising Energy prices inflation
and interest rates have taken the wind
out of the UK economy which had not
quite regained its pre-pandemic level
and tipped it into a recession we expect
to last for just over a year from last
quarter
inflation is expected to Peak at 11 this
year but would have peaked two and a
half percentage points higher without
the energy price guarantee
despite the government spending more
than 100 billion pounds over the next
two years to cushion the resulting for
natural squeeze on households and
businesses we expect to record seven
percent fall in living standards over
the next two years
these largely Global forces are putting
pressure on the government finances and
would have seen underlying debt on an
Ever Rising trajectory in the absence of
further policy action
to bring growth and debt under control
within five years the chances announced
30 billion pounds in tax Rises and 30
billion pounds in spending cuts in this
Autumn statement
but this still leaves the stock of
government debt 400 billion pounds
higher in five years time than we
assumed in our forecast back in March
and the more than doubling of interest
rates in the meantime pushes the share
of government resources consumed by the
cost of servicing that debt to its
highest level in a generation
this leaves the UK public finances more
sensitive to movements and interest
rates than they have been for decades
when these rates move in the
government's favor the fiscal Outlook
can improve by large sums
by way of illustration movements over
the past week and a half alone would add
around 10 billion pounds at the Headroom
against the Chancellor's goal of getting
underlying debt falling relative to
market the market expectations that are
forecast but it also leaves the public
finances more vulnerable to sudden
shifts in Market sentiment a full Taste
of which we had a few weeks ago and to
which the near doubling of debt interest
costs between March and our forecaster
test
and with that I now head things back to
Laura we'll be turning the question and
answer session thank you okay thank you
Richard uh so I think we'll reward those
who've ventured here in person and start
with a couple of questions in the room
if you could please wait for the
microphone to get to you and tell us who
you are and where you're from if you're
so if you so wish we'll start with uh
this lady here Chloe
hello there it's um Anna Isaac from the
guardian
um a couple of questions
um first um could you clarify why the
cost of
um taking of a bulb has risen so
significantly it's a very sharp increase
in the cost it's mentioned in a couple
of the footnotes and secondly and how
credible is the 61.7 billion tightening
um in 2027-28 obviously it's important
to determine um well the policy is up to
the politicians whether or not it is to
an extent deliverable and realistic in
terms of fiscal responsibility thanks
very much
uh can I ask Andy to take the bulb
question and then we'll come to Richard
on the second one
yes certainly the um the cost of the
bulb intervention has increased
essentially because it lasted for more
months than uh was factored into the
March forecast so the uh the transfer
talks bus has happened I think six
months later and that the the loss that
was incurred operating bulb in between
those those two time periods is the
additional cost
Instagram
I I can't offer you further detail but
that it's the monthly running loss of
Bolt
thanks Andy and Richard on The
credibility of the medium-term
tightening I'd say there's there's
always varying degrees of uncertainty
around uh
you know
likely outturns against our estimate of
the impact of different policy measures
um and as I alluded to in my remarks
some some policy measures we have to by
law put into our forecast like the fact
that fuel duty is going to rise in life
with inflation despite the fact that
every single chance that always
announces uh with with a few exceptions
in the recent past the fuel Duty gets
Frozen
um uh this on this particular occasion
there is a super indexation of of uh of
fuel Duty because it is RPI plus three I
I recall
um archives plus five sorry
um uh on top of what what is going to be
a very high RPI number this year and
that's why it brings in a 23 worth of
Revenue
um but there's also several billion
pounds um that if he doesn't go ahead
with the indexation would come off that
Headroom number uh on the spending side
at the moment there are these spending
plans sort of penciled in beyond the
current spending of your period but it
has also been a sort of well-established
pattern of Chancellor's past to pencil
in lower growth rates of spending before
spending a view happens but then as
they're spending a few draws nearer and
you have to make the tough choices of
allocating that money out chances have
tended to add 20 billion 30 billion
pounds to the overall envelope in order
to make their lives a bit easier when it
comes time to divide up the money
between between departments I'm not
saying this Chancellor is going to do
that thing or whoever is chancellor
doing the next spending if you're going
to do that but it has been a pattern of
behavior
um that your chances tend to tend to win
the day when you're setting overall
envelopes spending abuse that aren't
going to happen until several years
hence as those spending views draw
closer and your cabinet and you know
your cabinet colleagues start to call
you in the corridors
um and you need to agree things with the
Prime Minister and the cabin as a whole
it gets much harder and money gets
chucked into those envelopes to make to
make life easier
thanks Richard do we have any more in
the room to this gentleman here please
um Jack Bonnet from the city a.m um just
a couple of questions the first one one
clarification or you've got
um the interest burden hitting an
all-time high in terms of the the pace
of Rise is that also rising at a record
pace and then the second question is you
obviously mentioned there that public
Defiance is a more vulnerable to shocks
in financial markets kind of flip it
around and say our financial markets now
almost looking at us very intensely both
on how we reduce our deficit and also
whether or not we can get out of this
low growth malaise that we've been in
for a few years now
thanks Jack I'm going to ask Andy to
come in on the first of those and David
in a second on the second of those if
that's right so I I don't know for
certain but I would be amazed if it's
not the fastest rise it's um in the
short term it's very very uh heavily
influenced by RPI inflation which went
from very low to obviously very high
right now so uh as much as 75 billion
pounds worth of the debt interest
spending in this fiscal year is on index
linked debt
thanks idea and David on uh financial
markets yes I mean I think you're right
there is more focus in financial markets
on on the outlook for fiscal policy and
I don't think it's just in the UK
and it's partly because the stock of
debt is so much higher than it has been
in the past and it's on a rising
trajectory both here and in most other
developed economies
I think there's also uh partly because
of the
inflationary effects largely due to
energy and gas price and other commodity
prices
a natural increase in interest rates in
nominal terms that obviously adds to
Debt Service
costs
and perhaps also a perception now in the
bond markets that one might have been
living in a sort of false Paradise for
much of the last well 10 years where
both in nominal terms but particularly
in real terms people were willing to
lend money to governments at
extraordinarily low interest rates I'm
sure you'll know that if you take the
index link bond yields in the UK which
is a good measure of the real return
that people will get if they lend money
to the UK government
until relatively recently they were
about minus two and a half percent so
people were willing to lend the UK
government and lose two and a half
percent in some sense of what they LED
every year am I willing to do that on
bonds that had 40 years still to run and
they were doing that with other
countries as well and I think there's a
realization that
um that's not a very good deal in the
sense to bondholders so I think the new
the new reality is that real interest
rates will be higher for governments to
borrow pretty much across the world and
because the stock of debt is so much
higher pretty much across the world
government debt
um there is a bit more focus on how
affordable is is that and what are the
risks of not getting your money back so
I think that is
that is going to be with us for quite
some time
David we're going to switch a couple of
online questions and I will come back to
the room uh there's two or three that
are grouped together all on the same
topic
um an anonymous caller asks any thoughts
on what your for on why your forecast is
more optimistic than the bank of
England's uh gurpreet no one asks the
bank of England cautioned that in
probably high Market projections had
distorted its forecast are your own
forecasts being conditioned on Market
rates not affected by this same issue
and another anonymous person asks how
does your path for energy bills compare
with that assumed by the bank of England
so three questions on the differences
between our forecast and the bank of
England's uh I'll come to you first
David
um the bank of England's forecasts were
made um a little while ago uh and my
recollection is that they were
conditioning or Market expectations of
their own bank rate which were a bit
higher than we have right now and that
we've conditioned on we've taken for the
fiscal forecast we've taken Market
projections of where the bank rate will
go from early uh early ish in November a
few weeks ago the bank of England I
think we're using a few weeks before
that so that that's one factor I think
part of the reason instantly why Market
rates came down a bit was because of the
bank of England's own forecast which in
a sense confirmed a belief that maybe
Market expectations as they were back in
the middle part of October which is for
Bank Creek to get to six percent or so
would really
um consistent with the likely projection
of what was going to happen to inflation
so we've used a marginally lower
projection for short-term interest rates
than the bank did that will have a
little impact probably not a whole lot
on our forecast relative to theirs I
think a a bigger reason a more
significant reason why our forecast is a
bit more optimistic than the banks
is that we think it pretty likely that
the savings rates of the household
sector in the UK will fall very
substantially
perhaps even close to zero having the
very high
in the unusual circumstances of 20 20
and 2021 during lockdowns when it was
difficult for people to spend money uh
we think people are likely to dip those
that can anyway dip into some of the
excess savings they made back then
and that means that the projection we
have for consumer spending is a fair bit
stronger than the bank of England so I
think those two factors are the major
ones behind a slightly stronger forecast
that we have
um than the than the bank
on on the issue of whether or not we're
in using the market profile we may still
be overestimating the likely path for
bank rate
uh well that will depend it will depend
on how things play out to some extent it
is true that our forecast for inflation
based on
Market profile for interest rates which
is to get up to about five percent or so
for a short while then come back down to
four and dip beneath it a few years
further out than that our forecast for
inflation based on that does drop off
very sharply uh are you 18 months or so
down the road and falls into very mildly
negative territory
now one might think that that suggests
that we're using an unrealistic part of
bank rate I'm not so sure on that
because I think the bank of England is
likely to look look through temporary
very high inflation and temporary very
low inflation in setting monetary policy
so just as the bank of England is not
Now setting an interest rate to try and
bring inflation back to two percent by
Christmas
because if it did interest rates should
have to be about nine percent probably
it's not implausible that if inflation
temporarily dips beneath the target even
becomes slightly negative for a while
but then gets back to the Target they're
not going to get interest rates into
negative territory just because
inflation is sitting under the Target so
I think our forecast is really
conditioned on
plausible behavior of the members of the
monetary policy committee which is the
to some extent see through very sharp
overshoots and undershoots the inflation
Target and think we're underlying
inflation pressures are
thank you David we better come back to
the room I think we've got uh one person
over here Chloe the office of budget
responsibility the forecasters the
independent forecasters who we know how
important their work is of course
because we all remember what happened
when this trust and Cosby quantity
famously delivered their mini budget
without the accompanying obr forecast
they said I think gas prices are double
what they predicted in March interest
rates are twice as high and also living
standards down seven percent which
effectively wipes out eight years of
growth so some pretty gloomy uh
predictions from the obr and what it
means for all of us and how far our
money feels in real life well let's
bring in our Deputy political editor at
Sam Coates shall we who's been across
the Autumn statement uh this morning Sam
what's your main takeaways I mean in
many ways the awesome statement sort of
hurts the head because for three weeks
anybody paying attention to British
politics would have heard dire warnings
from Richie sunak and Jeremy Hunt about
just how difficult the task has been to
repair the public finances now some of
that as Jeremy Hunt said is
international because of global interest
rates because the war in Ukraine Energy
prices and some of that is mopping up
the job the mess behind left behind uh
by Liz truss and they made uh no bones
about the fact that today was going to
be incredibly difficult in order to calm
the markets and their view of the United
Kingdom and just how stable it is
essentially and then you get to today
and you discover that this year and next
year I think everyone's going to spend
more it's not a huge amount more a
couple of billion more but that must
enormous kind of changes below the
surface because there are lots of tax
Rises coming in income tax uh threshold
Rises top rate tax Rises coming in next
year but all of that's offset by and get
this you know like considerably highest
spending next year so to give you a sort
of sense of scale we're going to spend
in 2023 but 9 billion more than they
were before this morning
um they're going to tax about seven
billion more so overall it's a it's a
small increase but but despite all of
that Doom and Gloom they have felt that
over the next couple of years they need
to spend why is that because Jeremy Hunt
argues that Brit is already in a
recession and so the government needs to
do what it can to try and make that
recession more shallow to increase the
speed of growth where it can even if
it's in negative territory reduce
unemployment and generally try and and
help with that but but it's a very very
different message
um from the one that we were hearing on
for the last three weeks and it pushes
the pain that we've been hearing about
off to the right into a few years after
that a few years after that two years
time I mean I guess the skeptic of me
thinks well there's an election in two
years right is that a coincidence that
absolutely not and and when you look at
the numbers what you see is that the way
that Jeremy Hunter Richardson as it were
balanced the books which is code for
um they are projecting to bring down
debt to the borrowing levels to uh to
what they think is sustainable
um is by saying that in quite a lot of
years time they're going to spend less
uh than they otherwise would have done
on public services if they're in power
and that's the run because if you make
lots of promises about things that are
going to happen the other side of an
election everybody's going to turn
around and say well how do you know you
might not be in power you're not writing
the manifesto now might you decide that
because you want to win votes you're
going to spend more on health and
education local government and uh and
things like that but the important Point
Sophie is basically if the argument and
the is all aimed at the markets it's up
to them to decide whether they believe
near term as it were spending more and
long-term promises of cuts are credible
and and at this minute it it looks like
they probably do more or less it's early
days and there's not a great deal of
evidence but there's certainly no uh
reading there's no Ed Conway jumping up
at a screen um uh saying things are
going uh dramatically in the wrong
direction they're the audience and so
far they've bought it and it's worth
just looking at the politics what the
government wants to be able to say is we
helped support people through the
recession doing the best we can to make
it as shallow as possible and going into
the next Parliament what would labor do
if they wanted to promise more spending
does it mean yet higher tax cut tax
Rises given that we've already soaked
the rich uh drag more people into the
additional rate 45p top rate of tax
that'll now start at 125 rather than 150
000 done the kind of things that labor
would do where would they get that money
from they hope that's a winning argument
but there's a lot of pain ahead yeah
certainly is particularly looking at ABR
forecast Sam thank you very much for
your analysis we'll have more from Sam
at throughout at the afternoon but in
the meantime joining us now is Daisy
Cooper the deputy leader of the liberal
Democrats who is in central Lobby for us
what's your reaction to the Autumn
statement
well I think it's a cost
and it's going to
utilities and through weaker Public
Services we've already heard from the
obr that we are now in recession we've
also heard that we're going to have the
slowest rate of growth compared to every
other similar country and we also now
know that struggling families around the
UK are going to have the biggest fall in
living standards on record and I think
there's a devastating indictment about
the conservatives incompetence
um do you support the measures that have
been taken now and look like set your
point about the reasons that we are in
the situation the difficulty of the
situation we're in but looking forward
do you accept the mix of tax Rises and
some spending restraints but uh
postponed for a few years down the line
look this is a conservative mess and
this budget is designed to clear up the
mess that the conservatives themselves
the obr results have only just been
published uh in the last 40 minutes or
so and at the next at the next general
election the liberal Democrats will give
a fully costed Manifesto but it's
important to remember that just two
months ago nobody was talking about
spending cuts at all and the reason that
they have to be such Savage Cuts today
is because of the conservatives own mess
and their own incompetence
and but what would you do you must have
some plan for what you would do to as
you say clean up the chaos
you know what over the course of the
last year liberal Democrats have put
forward so many ideas and they've all
been fully costed we called for a proper
windfall tax more than a year ago uh the
conservatives windfall tax was brought
in six months late and it is so
pathetically weak that it hasn't raised
a single penny from Shell which has had
26 billion pounds but now they're
increasing it aren't they they're
increasing it substantially for windfall
tax
the conservative conservatives have
announced an increase in the rate of the
windfall tax but there is a loophole in
that tax which means a company like
shell has not paid a single penny and it
doesn't matter if you raise the rate if
you don't close that loophole they won't
pay a single penny but as I was saying
liberal Democrats have put forward ideas
about closing loopholes about reversing
the bank hand the handouts to the big
Banks we've talked about closing the the
loophole on capital gains for the 0.5
super wealthy in this country we have
kept putting forward ideas for the best
part of the Year whilst the
conservatives have just had a game of
deciding whose turn it is to be prime
minister it's their mess and they've got
to sort this out
do you support the pension triple lock
remaining which would see all pensioners
see their pensions go up by 10.1 next
year
that is because still in this country we
have a huge amount of pensioner poverty
and the reality is that many pensioners
have no ability to raise their income in
any other way so yes I do support the
retention of the triple lock I guess the
difficulty is you know a lot of people
public sector workers who would only
dream of an inflation matching pay rise
like that we'll be looking at it they'll
be thinking it's not means tested so
even the wealthy pensioners will benefit
and they don't feel like they have a way
of clicking their fingers and suddenly
getting a pay rise either
we absolutely should not be playing off
working people against pensioners or
anybody else the fact is that every
single person in this country is feeling
the pain right now as a result of the
conservatives mismanagement of the
economy every single person is now going
to have to pay the price to increase
taxes and through weaker Public Services
we shouldn't be playing people off each
other in this country we need to be
helping everybody
okay in order to do that then the money
needs to come somewhere do you support
the tax increases announced today
or the liberal Democrats are a party of
fair taxes and as I've said we proposed
a number of tax increases that could be
taken against the big oil and gas
companies the big Banks the nine the 0.5
super wealthy and all of those tax
increases on those people could help to
pay full tax decreases for those who are
not able to cope as well those are the
most modest incomes um low and middle
income families that is what the liberal
Democrats would like to see it's not
what the conservatives have done today
the conservatives have condemned every
single person in this country to higher
taxes and weaker Public Services okay
thank you very much for being on the
program today at Daisy Cooper there
uh well let's bring in Sam coats uh
shall we um Sam I just want to reflect
with you um it feels a lot after
speaking to Daisy from the lib Dems and
also speaking to tulips from labor
earlier there's lots of criticism many
will see it as entirely Justified of the
chaos that we're in and the fact it's
conservative it's their mess to clean it
up as
um Daisy Cooper said there
however there doesn't seem to be much
being put forward in the way of
alternative plans does that matter
I mean on one level I think uh that
it's hard for political parties
opposition parties to work out precisely
whether they would support this tax rise
or that tax rise uh in the minutes after
a budget but in a sense what I don't get
from either of those two parties the
liberal Democrats or labor party is a
real understanding of their entire
approach it's one thing to say well I'm
not quite sure about you know reducing
the threshold of 150 000 to 125 000 for
the 45 would be additional rate of taxes
nobody's going to judge them too much
much on that but but on the principles I
don't know where for instance labor is
Rachel Reeves told you at the weekend uh
on the Sunday show that she doesn't
think that the public sector can wear
spending cards okay
um but are we looking at tax Rises how
if you're going to be the party of
fiscal Prudence do you ensure that uh
you don't do big tax Rises uh if you're
going to public um if you're going to
try and promise spending Rises after the
next election I don't really understand
the basics of where the opposition
parties are coming from and so whilst I
think it's forgivable that you might not
know individual tax responses I I think
people don't know the big picture either
I think that is um perhaps uh fair I
guess and some would say that look you
know it is a conservative problem
they've been in power for 12 years and
why should it be for the opposition
parties to have to find a way out of it
and this is going to be the great big
gamble at the next election so you're
going to have the conservative party
going uh we helped if not fix the mess
then to make it less bad and look the
opposition parties have no answer to any
of the key questions and I think what
the opposition parties will want
particularly the labor party is people
to go look I'm just in really in pain a
seven percent drop into living standards
energy bills mortgages the cost of
living really putting a huge strain on
my individual uh experience I I don't
care whether or not a labor can answer
every single question it's just time for
a change and now in both of those
narratives don't necessarily require
labor to come up with detailed uh plans
they will come up with some probably a
lot closer to an election it's it's
which argument lands better with the
public and and where the nation's mood
is in two years time if that's when
there is election I mean looking at all
of the numbers in all the the books
today and listening to the office of
budget responsibility there I I don't
think life is going to be better in two
years time no certainly doesn't seem
that way does it um just finally Sam I
wonder if you've got A Bit of Sympathy
for the opposition parties looking at
their attack lines because just eight
weeks ago they were having to uh form an
opposition against Liz truss and
quasiquarting who seem to be doing
entirely the opposite policy uh to the
current government
well I never really have sympathy for
any politicians
even if they have quite a difficult job
but I mean whether you're an opposition
politician uh trying to work out a new
attack line or whether you're a
conservative MP having to you know beat
your chest and claim that you're
absolutely certain that the current
course of action is the right one having
insisted to your constituents at the
opposite course was absolutely the right
one just a month ago you know it's not
quite sympathy it's just more observing
with a raised eyebrow exasperation
perhaps Sam thank you very much indeed
for your analysis uh well let's go now
to Richard Thompson shall we who is the
snp's Deputy treasury spokesperson he's
also in parliament's a central Lobby for
us thank you for being uh with us what
did you make of the Autumn statement
well I thought it was a very
disappointing uh statement for all the
the trails that it had and for all the
uh increases in spending that the
chancellor has announced it's important
to remember that those are increases in
cash terms only and that with inflation
hitting today a 41 year high of 11.1
every single increase in spending that
has been announced is in effect a real
terms cut whether that's for uh public
services or whether it's uh in terms of
some of the welfare changes that were
announced and I think that a few were
somebody who woke up this morning
worried about how you were going to get
through the next few months and perhaps
even years of this cost of living crisis
you will still be left wondering that
this afternoon
and I was just reflecting with
um Sam coats that while many will see
the criticisms from the opposition
parties lib Dems and labor is very
Justified that it was the conservatives
12 years in power that have helped get
us into the current situation there
doesn't seem to be that much in the way
of a coherent alternative strategy being
laid out and I just wonder what is the
smp's plan to deal with the situation as
it is not right now forgetting how we
got here but what's the path forward
well I think I I I I appreciate the way
you want to frame that question but you
know we would we would not be starting
from the this point we wouldn't want to
be starting from here but nevertheless
here are some measures that the
chancellor could have put into his his
budget uh statement that would have
spread the burden more equitably uh it
could have done more of the windfall tax
instead of just making it apply to oil
and gas companies and energy companies
it could have included other companies
such as Amazon that are making very very
significant profits right now off the
back of the current situation it could
also unless you might not make this
might not have made the chancellor
terribly popular with these next door
neighbor in Downing Street but he could
have raised the further 3.2 billion
pounds by ending the non-domicile tax
status of any people but the real biggie
that was missed here is that many
companies are currently involved that
are making access profits are involved
in shared BuyBacks and if those were to
be taxed appropriately we could raise be
raising up to about 11 billion pounds
from that so and what was Builders
office School consolidation package of
55 billion pounds made up half and half
of tax increases and public spending
cuts straight away there's a package of
15 billion plus that could have been put
in there which would have shielded the
most vulnerable from the tax Rises that
are are going ahead and could actually
have helped to put more money in more
people's pockets to to help them through
the difficult times that we're
experiencing at the moment
there are significant increases to
personal
announced today whether the hire owners
with the extension of the 45p rate or
also at many other millions of workers
as well with the freezing of the tax
thresholds do you support those changes
uh yes I think that's a reasonable way
to to go about uh trying to trying to
raise a greater amount of money from the
tax base that's there but uh you know I
think at this moment in time I would be
remiss if I didn't reflect on the
planned 45 Pence rate cut and how uh the
the political opponents of the Scottish
national party in Scotland were
clamoring particularly the conservatives
to ensure that that was replicated in
Scotland I think we've seen the Folly of
that uh thoroughly exposed and
repudiated in this budget and I think
some of that fiscal drag that had that
was inevitable to some extent but
nevertheless was in a situation where
public services are going to suffer
where our investment is going to fall in
real terms because of the inflation that
is out there where people are still
going to be struggling to make ends meet
with the bills that they're facing and
with the chancellor has missed some
significant opportunities to increase
the tax revenue and I've just given
three examples they're they're just now
missed some significant opportunities to
take and significantly higher tax
levels which would have allowed them to
do more to detect the most vulnerable
and to make sure that we were investing
properly in the things that we need to
like our Capital budgets capital
expenditure programs right across the
public sector and also in research and
development if they really want to shift
the dialogue and growth these are the
things that they really needed to be
hitting in this Autumn statement simply
hasn't done that okay thank you very
much uh indeed there Richard Thompson of
the SNP
now you might be wondering how all of
this affects you if you scan the QR code
on your screen right now you can ask
your very own questions about how the
Autumn statement will impact you and
your family at 4 30 this afternoon we're
going to be holding a q a with a
personal finance expert Gemma Godfrey so
do stay with us we'll try and answer as
many questions as we can
now in the meantime our business
presenter Ian King is in the city for us
and in we're in a recession uh if we're
going to get out of it of course we need
businesses to play their part was there
much for them in the Autumn statement
thin pickings really I would say Sophie
I mean obviously there was a big
windfall tax on the North Sea oil and
gas producers and one on electricity
generators for the first time although
it's worth pointing out that that had
been pretty well priced in by the market
and in one or two cases you're actually
seeing some of the share prices of the
businesses affected Rising I think one
of the most interesting winners is the
insurance sector because the chancellor
has unveiled uh changes to what's known
as solvency too now these are the rules
governing the amount of capital that
insurance companies have to keep on
their balance sheets it was a eu-wide
measure so obviously the UK's departure
from the EU has given the government
scope to do something on that front it's
taken an awful long time to get here a
lot of tuning and throwing the insurance
companies gave their views so too did
the bank of England it looks as though
the treasury has actually overruled some
of the banks concerned because it looks
as though the insurance companies are
going to be able to deploy more capital
in the way that they see fit so that is
it's good news for the insurance actor
they've argued that if they're allowed
to do that it will enable them to invest
in very long-term infrastructure
projects for example building more
rented accommodation adding energy
generating capacity just to name two
examples so I think that's something
that will be seen as fairly positive
the other winner I guess is the banking
sector now this is because the banks on
top of corporation tax they pay an
additional profits Levy that was
something that George Osborne slapped on
them a number of years ago now obviously
uh with the corporation tax Rising if
the chancellor had kept that in place it
would have meant that the rate of
corporation tax being paid by the Banks
would have risen to as much as 33 so Mr
Hunt has tapered that away taken that
away it still means that in the round
the banks will probably be paying
slightly more uh in uh in taxes than
they were but they're not paying
anything like as much as they had been
threatened with initially so you could
say they're some of the winners
um elsewhere we've been promised some
sort of uh tweaks some elements of
relief on business rates which is
obviously a huge bug bear for the retail
and Hospitality sectors the hospitality
trade Association really giving it two
cheers rather than three they would have
liked a Wholesale route and Branch
reform of the kind the labor party is
promising we haven't got that today but
it will no doubt help in the short term
the other big question Sophie is what
happens to support for businesses when
the current package with energy bills
runs out at the end of March now the
government is reviewing this but they've
basically put uh businesses on notice
they need to start thinking carefully
about Energy Efficiency measures
Ian thank you very much for guiding us
through that now the chancellor Jeremy
Hunt confirmed in his statement that
pensions will increase in line with
inflation it's the biggest ever increase
in the state payment Jeremy Hunt told
pensioners that the government is on
their side as it says people will get an
extra
870 pounds while sky is Sally Lockwood
is in Wolverhampton where business
owners and Shoppers have been listening
to what the chancellor has announced
today Sally
hi again Sophie yes certainly we've been
absorbing reaction here to the Autumn
statement from the chancellor there are
significant uh communities that suffer
from significant deprivation up here in
Wolverhampton and certainly a number of
people are struggling already to make
ends meet let alone uh looking at some
of this forecasting by the obr today
that's seven percent uh will fall in
disposable income many people don't have
a disposable income as things stand
right now and certainly uh one person
that I've just been speaking to is a
pensioner here in Wolverhampton who I'm
delighted to introduce you to Mark
Cooper who's given me his reaction as
well to today's Autumn statement uh hi
Mark thanks for joining us thank you so
that guarantee that pensions will be
triple locked they will rise with
inflation your reaction that's a that's
a bonus I didn't expect that at all in
view of the fact they've canceled it a
couple of times so and what sort of a
difference will that make to you how
worried were you well
anything that reduces a pension which is
which is the lowest in Europe is a
problem uh the basic state pension is
145 pounds a week
or circumstances if you don't mind me
asking retired what 15 years ago that's
right yeah and do you have a private
pension and a state pension how does it
work basically the state pension just
and okay is that is that tough to
survive on at the moment it's difficult
it is difficult it comes in and goes out
there's nothing left over
for saving or you know emergencies and
with the um energy crisis it's made even
more difficult because we cannot um
afford to have the heating off
we lived there 24 7 basically we don't
leave so had you not had that guarantee
today that your pension would rise in
line with inflation what would that have
meant for you well it would it would
have made it quite difficult actually
um
I can't give you a financial cost but
um it's a difference between three
percent and eleven percent
you know so that's quite a quite a a
large amount now
as you're describing you know some
really do struggle to survive on that
state pension but other pensioners are
very well off is this a bribe for votes
it's difficult I wouldn't like to count
on that really because I'm I'm not a
well-off pensioner
um we just get by and uh so the same
kindness should the same kindness be
extended to nurses absolutely nurses
have done us a proud job with a coverage
19. so pensioners have had this
guarantee today Nurses haven't and of
course young people are going through a
very tough time going into really
looking for older Generations like
yourself that's right well that's the
way it's worked for centuries doesn't it
we paid for our predecessors and but now
we have an aging
per week absolutely yeah yeah yeah we
have it's it's a problem I don't know
the solution to be honest
unless I can go out to work again
yeah I'm sure you've earned to your
retirement but uh Mark thanks so much
it's a pleasure for speaking to us thank
you lovely to meet you certainly there's
been a mixed reaction here um you know
very
um welcome news for pensioners like Mark
that uh the increase has been uh
guaranteed today that pensions will uh
rise in line with inflation and so will
benefits but certainly here in
Wolverhampton there's very high youth
unemployment there are large areas of
deprivation people here are already
struggling uh to make ends meet research
last month showed that one in five
people in poor areas of the West
Midlands are already skipping meals to
try and pay their bills and make ends
meet at the end of the month it is a
frightening time financially for people
in many areas like Wolverhampton but for
now back to safely in Westminster
at Sally thank you very much indeed for
giving us a picture of the difficult
times people are experiencing in
Wolverhampton really reflected across
the country as well with that pretty
brutal obr prediction that living
standards are going to be falling seven
percent uh so your spending power is
going to be down no matter what is
announced in the Autumn statement today
it's three o'clock you are watching it's
a special coverage of the Chancellor's
Autumn statements a big fall in people's
disposable incomes ahead as the
chancellor announces a raft of measures
to fill a 50 billion pound black hole
there may be a recession made in Russia
but there is a recovery made in Britain
[Applause]
and we commit to our plan today with
British resilience and British
compassion
the mess we are in is the result of 12
weeks of conservative chaos but also 12
years of conservative economic failure
a reduction in the 45p tax rate
threshold which means those earning 150
000 pounds of War will pay over 1 200
pounds more a year
but a boost for the NHS as Jeremy Hunt
increases the budget for Health Care by
3.3 billion pounds
and a warning that households will face
increased energy bills High inflation
and tax hikes as the country enters
recession
also announced today a big increase in
the windfall tax on energy companies and
a new tax on electricity generators
it's all about the cost of living here
in Wolverhampton where I've been
speaking to business owners workers and
Shoppers who've been giving me their
reaction to the Chancellor's plans
telling me how it's going to affect
their finances
foreign
and Welcome to our special coverage of
the Autumn statement the chancellor has
promised to rebuild the UK economy in
the House of Commons today however
households will face increased energy
bills High inflation and tax hikes with
disposable incomes forecast to drop by a
record seven percent Jeremy Hunter
Chancellor said he was having to make
difficult decisions to stabilize the
economy but the shadow Chancellor Rachel
Reeves accused the conservatives of
picking the pockets purses and wallets
of the entire country let's take a
closer look now at some of the measures
that have been announced today Energy
bill support for households will be
extended Beyond April for a further year
although the energy price guarantee bill
for the annual household will be 3 000
pounds that is up from 2 500 pounds for
the average household that is the NHS
budget is to be increased in each of the
next two years by an extra 3.3 billion
pounds
and the pensions triple lock will be
protected pension credit is to rise by
10.1 percent that's worth up to 1470
pounds for a couple and 960 pounds for a
single pensioner
the chancellor said that working age and
disability benefits will also be
upgraded with inflation that means an
increase of 10.1 percent at a cost of 11
billion pounds
and a windfall tax on Major Oil and Gas
producers will be raised to 35 that's up
from 25 and as well as this an energy
profits Levy rate of 45 will be imposed
on electricity generators with the
chancellor saying that will raise 14
billion pounds next year
we're Jeremy Hunt also reduce the
threshold of the top rate of tax the 45p
rate now becomes payable at 125 140
pounds that's down from the current
level 150 000 pounds
and on education the government said
that they will invest an extra 2.3
billion pounds a year in schools next
year and the year after
it's a pretty wide-ranging package of
measures there let's take a listen to
the chancellor when he spake in the
House of Commons earlier today
there is a global energy crisis a global
inflation crisis and a global economic
crisis but the British people are tough
inventive and resourceful we have risen
to bigger challenges before we aren't
immune to these headwinds but with this
plan for stability growth and public
services we will face into the storm
there may be a recession made in Russia
but there is a recovery made in
[Music]
[Applause]
commit to our plan today with British
resilience and British compassion
because of the difficult decisions we
take today we strengthen our public
finances bring down inflation protect
jobs we build the first state-backed
nuclear power station for 30 years we
continue the biggest program of capital
investment for 40 years we protect
standards in schools cut NHS waiting
times fund social care cat energy bills
support those on benefits we protect
workers with the biggest ever increase
in the National living wage and our
pensioners on the triple lock we're the
biggest ever increase in the state
pension this is a balanced plan for
stability a plan for growth and a plan
for public services it shows that you
don't need to choose either a strong
economy or good public services with
conservatives and only with
conservatives you get both
uh Jeremy Hunt there outlining his
vision for the economy in the Autumn
statements but in a pretty firing
opening response so she had a Chancellor
argued that the Autumn statement would
not leave British people better off
Rachel Reeves claimed the public would
still be forced to pay more because of
the destruction that the conservative
party has caused
the mess we are in
is the result of 12 weeks of
conservative chaos but also 12 years of
conservative economic failure
growth dismal investment down wages
squeezed Public Services crumbling and
what does the chancellor have to offer
today more of the same with working
people paying the price for his failure
the chancellor should have come here
today to ask for forgiveness
released he could have offered an
apology but
but instead he says that his predecessor
was correct in his analysis at the mini
budget the mini budget that put our
economy into free fall
all the country got today was an invoice
for the economic Carnage that this
government has created never again can
the conservatives be seen as the party
of economic competence
well that was uh Rachel Reeves and
Jeremy Hunt in the House of Commons
earlier now the office for Budget
responsibility has given a pretty dire
forecast for the next few years as
households really feel the pinch they
forecast that the economy would be in a
recession for just over a year with GDP
falling 2.1 percent unemployment is
expected to rise by 505 000 to 4.9
percent that's by the Autumn of 2024.
meanwhile house prices are also expected
to fall nine percent across the next two
years
and the combination of a recession and
the highest inflation in 40 years will
result in a historic fall in living
standards by Autumn 2024 households will
be 7.1 percent poorer that's a worst
fall since records began
in the near term inflation to far
outpaces growth and nominal wages which
are expected to grow by six percent this
year and four percent next year
this drives historically large Falls in
per person real disposable income which
dropped by a cumulative seven percent
over the two Financial years to 2023-24
wiping out the last eight years of
improvement
this steepfully living standards happens
despite the energy price guarantee and
other government support which raise
real incomes by three and a half percent
on average this year and next
however for a net energy importer like
the UK the huge increase in global gas
prices over the past year represents the
terms of trade shock that leaves our
country as a whole forum
so our government policy can through
spending Taxation and borrowing alter
who in the UK pays for these high energy
costs within and between Generations it
cannot make them go away
indeed we expect real incomes in 2027 to
still be one percent below their
pre-pandemic peak of three years ago
well with us now is our Deputy political
editor Sam Coates and Samuel we've been
talking about the tax changes we're
talking about when the spending cuts are
going to fall but really is the big
story today that very depressing
forecast that we've been hearing from
the obr living standards fall seven
percent highest on record wiping out
eight years of growth I mean this is
pretty depressing stuff that's right
when you put together the highest tax
burden since the second world war that
seven percent drop in people's living
standards which is the highest on record
the nine percent drop uh in house rise
uh in house prices
um over the next year and a half or so
uh rises in unemployed employment and um
just people suffering because they're
having to pay more uh tax I think
something like 5.8 million more people
paying that additional uh higher rate of
tax yes it's going to be incredibly
difficult and I think today what you've
had actually from the government is as
much as anything else a strategy uh what
Jeremy Hunt said he was going to do was
to fill a massive black hole that behind
partly by his predecessor and partly as
a result of all the turmoil that's going
on around the world but what he's ended
up doing is spending more over the next
two years quite incredible that he said
that he needed to spend a lot less to
reduce borrowing to make Britain less
risky uh and he's ended up over this
couple of years extending the energy
price guarantee which just a month ago
was too risky uh to keep in place he's
ended up uh spending more on schools and
hospitals and social care in fact in
order he would say to get people through
these very tough times and then there
are according to him and according to
the documents released by government
today going to be pretty uh big squeezes
after the next election but you and I
know Sophie that that's
a bit presumptive not a word of any
Manifesto has been written we don't know
who's going to be in power you can't
just do that but but in one sense
already it feels like that gamble has
paid off because if that gamble is aimed
at the markets there's no great uh
terminal there he's it as it were
banking on the credit that he's already
got together with Rishi Cena and calming
everything down and then spending some
of that credit up front in order to try
and ameliorate make less bad some of the
challenges uh that people are going to
face over the next two years but
promising Grim stuff if he ever gets to
it in the next parliamentary time of a
conservative government yeah really um
it does feel I guess our sort of
skeptical hat on for that but as you say
perhaps all of those interviews you did
before all that pitch rolling him and
the Prime Minister talking about the eye
watering difficult uh decisions uh thank
you very much uh Sam let's bring in
Econo shall we our economics and data
editor who've been you've been crunching
the figures all day what stood out to
you was it I mean there's been a
striking day we've had so many different
kind of data points so many different
changes on precisely you know what the
story is for the UK economy
but let's start with the kind of the big
picture because it is worth just looking
uh at where we are so what does this
Autumn statement really mean for the
states of the economy first of all let's
look at growth gross domestic products
what you're seeing here is just a kind
of measure of how big total GDP is and
what is GDP is just a measure of
national income how much we're all
generating across the country and then
we get we should get to share it with
each other back before the pandemic the
line was going up and up and up we were
getting better and better off then of
course came the pandemic you can maybe
just about spot it there and again the
expectation was we were going to go up
and up and up but note that that line
there that red line wasn't reaching
where we were before that's earlier on
this year but now look at what the bank
of England has just forecast the bank of
England forecast again that we're going
to Flatline now I'm going to bring on
the latest obr forecast the one we just
got today the critical one from the
government again the same thing we are
in recession right now what you're
seeing there that fall in those lines
means we're in recession but gradually
starting to improve after that but
here's the key thing look that red line
there is far below those two lines in
other words we are less wealthy less
well off doing less well than we thought
we would have been only a few months ago
and indeed a few years ago and that Gap
builds up over time and it means you're
less well off and one other measure of
looking at how well off or otherwise we
are is to look at this this is real
household disposable income basically
when these bars are above the line it
means we're getting having more money in
our pockets each year when they're below
the line well it's the opposite and last
time around back in March
look at what happened there these are
forecast by the way these next few lines
the obr last time thought that we were
going to have the worst year for
household disposable income on record
going all the way back to the 1950s that
this starts in the 1950s now I'm going
to kind of update this bit here to show
you what their latest forecast is so
have a look at that area there
it's even worse in fact it's two years
first of all they're going further down
but it's the worst two years in modern
history for real household disposable
income that's miserable it means it's
not just a recession but it's kind of
recession that you really do feel
intimately in your pockets and that's
not the only thing that's worth just
noticing here partly that's a
consequence by the way of higher
inflation as is the fact that this debt
interest spending is going up as well
this is what the government spends on
its test interest and it means that
basically the deficit is higher each
year then have a look that's going up as
well getting to the highest level that
we have ever seen so that's a
consequence of inflation it's a
consequence of higher uh debt as well
listen there's consequence too of the
fact that a lot of that debt is indexed
links as well so inflation linked and
that's not the only record look at this
taxes the total amount the tax burden
that some people call it of taxes as a
percentage of GDP the exact thing that
Liz trust was very concerned about she
was bewailing the fact that back in
March it was pointing towards the
highest level on record or certainly
back to the 1940s well now we are
heading up to what is actually the
highest level on record that's where we
are so higher taxes this time around all
those different changes and the
allowances and so on that pulls more
people into tax and means as a country
we are becoming a higher tax country not
as high as some in Europe but
nonetheless that's a big change uh there
but the final thing that's just worth
noting I mean the big story last time
around of course was what happened in
markets and in particular the way that
markets had their expectations for
future interest rates changed massively
well the big question this time around
was would these lines which went up
that's February uh that's August and
what we're showing you here is just
future expectations that was the mini
budget and the big question as I say
this time was were we going to see this
line go anywhere higher it went up to
6.4 the expectation for interest rates
last time around just before this uh
Autumn statement it was around there
about kind of four and a half percent
what happened this time around have a
look
it went up a little bit but barely
anything at all so actually we were
talking about the market reaction this
chart or something like it is precisely
the thing the government will be looking
at and saying to itself well actually
that didn't go badly given how badly the
mini budget went down we didn't see it
going up really high in fact it stayed
relatively low so they'll be happy with
that but all told you know the economic
story here about the state of the
economy about the state of the public
finances there's very little to be all
that reassured by
if you scan the QR code on your screen
right now you can ask your very own
questions about how the Autumn statement
is likely to affect you at 4 30 this
afternoon we're going to be holding a q
a with a personal finance expert Gemma
Godfrey so definitely worth staying with
us for that and do submit your questions
we'll be talking an awful lot about the
hit to household budgets but let's go
now to the city and talk to our business
presenter Ian King about what this all
means for businesses uh in how they're
going to be reacting
well it varies uh Sophie who you speak
to obviously the biggest pain will be
felt by the North Sea oil and gas
producers they've seen a rise in the
energy windfall tax levy uh by 10
percentage points from 25 to 35 that
actually takes the top rate uh the the
tax rate paid by these producers to 75
percent meanwhile the electricity
generators have also been hit with a 45p
uh profits Levy as well on the
extraordinary returns those were the
Chancellor's words that they have been
enjoying that largely looks have been
priced in by the market already though
the share prices of many of these
companies has actually risen uh today
actually having been really really
spanked over uh recent weeks uh for
example Central British gas they own a
fifth of the UK's remaining nuclear
power plants their Shares are actually
up five percent as I speak some of the
nauseon and gas producers have continued
to fall though elsewhere there is good
news for the banking sector now they've
been subject to an extra profits Levy
which was put in place by George Osborne
the best part of a decade ago well that
was going to be tweaked when the
chancellor what the last chance of
quasi-karting said he wasn't going to uh
go ahead with corporation tax increases
now that um Mr Hunt is going ahead with
corporation tax increases next year
quite a big one six percentage points in
all well he's tweaked the prophets Levy
that the banks pay accordingly he's
bringing that down to uh protect them
from otherwise having to pay a tax rate
of some 33 so that's reasonably good
news for some of the banks you've seen
for example shares of Roy's banking
group one of the big lenders there up
this afternoon and there's also good
news for the insurance sector and that
is because the government has decided to
make changes to what's known as solvency
too now this is the eu-wide capital rule
that dictates the amount of capital that
insurers have to keep tied up on their
balance sheets now that the UK's left
the EU there is flexibility to do
something about that it's something that
the insurance companies have been
clamoring for very interestingly it
looks as though the treasury has
overruled the bank of England's record
recommendations on that there will be
more Capital freed up for the insurance
companies to deploy as they wish and
that potentially is quite good news for
growth because you would expect a lot of
that to be tied up in long-term
infrastructure projects so for example
build to rent projects of the type that
legal in general have been doing so
those are all relatively uh good pieces
of news for businesses obviously you've
got a promised tweak to some business uh
rate reliefs that is something that will
come of uh help to the retail sector and
the hospitality sector but only really
at the margins they've given it two
cheers you could say or even only the
one because what they wanted was a root
and Branch reform of uh corporate of
business rates of the kind that the
labor party has promised to undertake so
there's a lot more work to be done on
that and I think the other big Point
obviously the the big big elements in in
this Autumn statement and also in quasi
quaten's mini budget which have remained
in place is the extraordinary support
that's been given to both households and
businesses with their energy bills all
of that announced by quasi-karting has
stayed in place all uh businesses in
particular were looking to see what the
government had to say today about the
support that they can look forward to
when the existing release run out at the
end of March next year now what Jeremy
Hunt said here was that there is going
to be a review of the support packages
but he's basically put them on notice
you can't expect the sort of support
that we've been giving you so far to
keep going and as you'll be using this
time to implement Energy Efficiency
measures and other cost-saving measures
it looks as though any support for the
business sector in future with energy
bills is going to be very highly
targeted I just tell you what the
markets are doing Sophie
um very little change to be honest uh
very little reaction on the guilt Market
which is as I said was just talking you
through the expectations on where
interest rates Peak uh well it's the
same with uh with guilts that's a UK
government iOS or bonds the yield is an
implied borrowing cost and those have
really remained unchanged over the
course of the session very slightly
higher but nothing to really scare the
horses the pound well it's off about one
percent right now against the US dollar
but it's had a couple of really good
days against the Greenback it uh hit a
three-month High against the US dollar
48 hours ago and the 4100 well apart
from uh some of these moves that affect
individual energy companies footsie's
pretty much unchanged on the session as
well you rarely see the stock market
reacting uh very much on on budget days
and uh today is no exception really
although of course uh in you and I both
remember what the markets did at the
last uh financial event the mini budget
so I guess uh no news is perhaps good
news thank you very much for the update
what we're talking there to Ian about
the impact on businesses let's go to Sky
Sally Lockwood shall we who's in
Wolverhampton talking to business owners
and also Shoppers who've been listening
into what the chancellor announced today
Sally
yeah hi again Sophie well when you talk
about trying to bridge the gap between
what's being said in Westminster and how
people are feeling in parts of the
country like Wolverhampton Wolverhampton
is a good example this is where the
government Department the leveling up
department is based it was opened under
Boris Johnson's Premiership it's been
open for around 18
months why here well perhaps because
Wolverhampton does feel in the shadow of
its neighbor Birmingham but also this is
a very marginal area in terms of
politics they have three constituencies
that make up Wolverhampton two turned
blue in the last election one was a
labor hold and here to discuss the
Autumn statement with me and give me
their reaction is a labor counselor and
a conservative counselor for
Wolverhampton thank you so much for
joining us so we've got Ian Brookfield
who is the labor leader of Wolverhampton
Council and Adam Collins uh your
reaction first if I may Ian to what
Jeremy Hunt had to say today
yeah sure I mean it certainly is a it's
a dark day outside from Wolverhampton no
doubt the rest of the country but I
think the mood music and some of the
announcements will perhaps keep our
country and some of these people in a
dark place for a long time and that
really worries and actually upsets me so
what a great day but some
saying well actually this is a budget
that could have easily been presented by
the opposition in terms of some of its
policies today
um obviously some of the policies but
then again I don't think we lost 65
billion pounds five weeks ago and I'm
sure some of this budget today is to
cover it for that failure five weeks ago
uh Adam your response has not been an
easy period for the conservatives has it
there were no easy decisions today
absolutely not and I think there's no
there's no hiding away that next couple
of years
um will be tough for families you know
there are there are inflation issues
cost of living issues I think look at
some of the announcements though today
in the budget you've got commitment to
the triple lock
um raising benefits in line with
inflation raising the national minimum
wage commitment to household support
funds for the next 12 months you know
all those different things will combine
and and and and help to mitigate not
fully solve there's more energy help
coming I think an extra 900 pounds for
the most vulnerable and these are these
are critical thing things which are
going to be so important to Residents
throughout Wolverhampton Ian what
difference has the leveling up HQ made
to Wolverhampton do you know what it's
probably one of the only instances where
where I actually agree with the policy
to actually bring out and this was the
first
um the first White Hall Department to
come out of London and and come out into
into the into the regions and so what
that's given us is the ability to Talk
liaise work together with government
officials and yes we've even had second
series of States visits and so that's
helped us in in our ambition to
regenerate you know we want to be a a
region that's that that's that's
obviously green looking at modern
methods of construction that's housing
and that has certainly helped us so I
can't deny that as being of benefits do
you feel like you're being heard more
I have to say it probably makes sense
that that that government's saying most
people up north sometimes get a bit a
bit a bit leery or a bit wary of what
happens down down in in London the
capital so I think it's always a good
policy that you'd evolved power you've
evolved information you've devolved
these links right down to a local level
so like I said before credit where
credit's due that has probably been of
great benefits very brief thought Adam
Before I Let You Go why is youth
unemployment so high here
it goes back many many years and it is a
real real concern it goes back to um you
know education and skills and I think
it's absolutely critical in the in the
statement that there's more money now
dedicated to education and that's going
to be a major boost I think moving
forward
um we've got issues with businesses
moving out of the city as well over the
years high levels of deprivation and I
think it's about children being left
behind and I think this is you know this
is why leveling up is so important to
create those jobs and invest in our
children's Futures Adam College in
Brookfield thank you very much for
speaking to us uh certainly we've had
mixed reaction to that uh Chancellor's
statement today but certainly people
here in the West Midlands already making
very difficult decisions decisions when
it comes to their finances one in five
people in the poorest areas of this
region are already